I'm James C. Cox.
I'm the Noah Langdale Jr.
Chair in Economics, the Georgia Research Alliance Eminent Scholar,
and Director of the Experimental Economic Center at Georgia State University.
I'm an experimental and behavioral economist,
which if you wondered,
what does an economist have to do with actual delivery of healthcare?
The words experimental and behavioral are the keys.
Because the centers of my areas of expertise are how
people respond to incentives and use information in making decisions,
and how one can design mechanisms to help them improve the decisions that they make.
In this case, the problem to be addressed is not lack of information.
Physicians are overwhelmed with information and the problem we face is how to use it.
Where my team at the Experimental Economic Center comes in is
to start with a large sample of the identified patient records,
do an analysis of that data to try and find
the predictors of unsuccessful and successful discharge from the hospital,
and then build on that a clinical decision support system with user
friendly displays that can aid the physicians in making better decisions.
First of all, the economist did the data analysis and then my I.T.
staff design the original CDSS that we used in experiments here at Emory.
We ran experiments with both resident physicians and fourth year medical students.
Initially, they were making decisions about virtual patients being represented
by computers for trained data of real patients.
We later did an experiment where we had patient actors called standardized patients.
There were two sources of information which
was the CDSS and the behavior of these standardized patients,
and this is the last step
before being ready to go out on the patient wards with an intervention.
Getting prepared to go take that last step onto
the patient wards is where we encountered really serious problems.
Because at that point,
we needed a version of the CD SS that can
interact with electronic health records in real time.
When we started to try and take that step,
we ran into very severe obstacles because you can
imagine protecting patient information is a central concern,
and we were asking for two-way communication.
At that point, both Cerner Corporation and Emory I.T.
essentially balked.
We were in near despair in not being able to get cooperation from Cerner and Emory I.T.
in trying to make the next step in getting out of
the laboratory and onto the patient wards.
We had a meeting here at Emory with the new director of Emory IT.
And he made us aware of
the fire standards and he invited Mark Grunstein to come,
who said to us, Well,
you've hit a brick wall,
but I know how to get through that brick wall.
And it is using fire compliance which is forthcoming.
And he provided to us the information we needed for the path forward and also provided
a path to start to walk down that path through
the projects that his class teams could do for us.
We were enthusiastic about learning about that path,
and having that opportunity to start walking down that path.
One of the project teams working on an initial version of
the app produced some alternative,
very nice displays of the information,
and this is critical because for the CDS to have value,
it has to have two properties.
One is it makes correct predictions about probability of
re-admission of a patient if you discharge them on any given day.
But the other thing it needs to do is to present the information in a user-friendly way.
So here's what in principle the problem to be solved.
The underlying model looks at each patient as though
as an individual patient that comes from a population of a very large sample,
for which we know the outcomes of previous decisions,
where a patient that looks like your individual patient today,
out of a very large sample of 30 or 40 thousand patients.
If you discharge your patients today,
do they look statistically more like
ones who it was unsuccessful and they were re-admitted,
or it was successful and they were not?
The critical thing then is not only to have the underlying correct predictions,
but to display them in a way that the physicians will actually find it easy to use.
And one of the class teams produce
these beautiful information displays and there are two of them.
One of them presents the information and is like rectangular block format,
another in a beautiful circular format.
But the nature of the information displayed is in
the lower left hand corner of the display,
is something that shows the probabilities of re-admission for patients,
and it'll show the time sequence
from the first day your patient was in the hospital up to the current day.
It displays the point estimate of the probability of re-admission,
unplanned readmission if you discharge them today,
and the 80% error bounds.
The center of the display
shows all of the variables in the patient's record including labs,
vitals, all the information,
and those displays are color coded.
And the color coding represents
the marginal significance on
probability of re-admission of each of those individual variables.
The user, then, can click on any one of those variable names in
the central display and that will open up on the right side of the screen.
The detailed information on that individual variable for
your patient including how it varied from the day admission up to the current day,
and how that time path of those readings compares
to the normal range of that particular variable.